okay
we're back on overtime uh donna who will
be the democratic candidate in 2024 ah
are you surprised by kamala harris's
lack of support
um i i i believe it's joe biden he's
announced that he's going to run for
reelection i haven't seen any signs that
he is throwing in the towel so i got to
stick with joe biden until i
i know something else
no if he decides not to run i got a long
list bill if you want to get on my list
call me
you definitely don't want to be on the
list
but like going to be worried about
running he's going to be worried about
walking
you can't run now oh
that's ageist yeah well very much so
it's ages but
you're allowed to be ages if the guy's
the pilot of an airplane that you're in
right
but i mean i feel like that's a a
self-fulfilling prophecy they
lots of people have it in their interest
that he is
gonna act senile and
i mean
you know everybody who is on camera that
much
is going to make some gaps and let's be
honest he was a gaff machine when he was
40. he's
he's actually better yeah he makes less
gaps now probably because he's aware of
it more and he's president
but i i just don't see this that he is
that different than he was 10 20 years
ago i mean we heard that argument back
and and you know when donald trump said
that he was in his basement now he was
in his baiting trying to beat trump's
ass he did
wow
i mean i but
don't you think somebody like michelle
obama would be much better than yeah
oh my god yes you want to add tomorrow
she's not going to run
oh she's well running no but of course
she would be better yeah i just i think
that's a winner i mean i think i think
that's right democratic winners hold
that thought just in case we need
another candidate in 2028 just all that
i mean it's not like no one has thought
of that it's it's that she won't it's
she's not
obama foundation they put in their time
for eight years they paid the price they
paid yes they served the country so you
know
[Applause]
okay uh
mark in your book you write about a
white house meeting with venezuela's
opposition leader where they casually
talked about assassinating the
venezuelan president
uh is that true no that's that's not
true and that's not what i wrote what he
talked about was
you know the president said to
the acting president of venezuela you
know would you
if we would you support us attacking the
country or doing a military operation
wait a minute let's set what year is
this
uh late 20 no early 2020 january
february 2020 the president was madero
no well the pr the president in
venezuela was madaro yeah the acting
interim president was uh juan guido
right the uh right yeah who knew the
opposition right who never got right so
what were they so
we're sitting in the oval office and the
president brings up this discussion our
president about would the united states
if the united states conducted military
action against venezuela what would the
venezuelan people do or the opposition
people something like it was along those
lines i write about it briefly in the
book but that's like every
administration does that
talked about and then conducted
assassinations they didn't just talk
about it they did it
well but the word assassination is not
in there it was discussion about
military options okay
i'm just
i'm listening
that's a good polish that would be one
thing with trump that wasn't a break
from the norm yeah like if somebody's a
problem overseas hmm kill
them anyone bill you had another idea
but the discussion about taking action
against venezuela continues all the way
through at least until the fall of 2020.
this keeps coming up and up all right um
should democrats run more candidates
like john fetterman
yes who is he i don't know who that is
he is the senate candidate for the state
of pennsylvania the current lieutenant
governor he had a stroke so he's
recovering he had a stroke
yes he had a stroke how old was he 52.
52.
wow joe biden hasn't had a stroke no
but what i feel like i feel like you're
a defense of joe biden he was always mad
at talking
but it's true i know
it's not the age issue but john this
[ __ ] had a stroke at 52. wow
you don't even know the man they're
going to call him a big board of mf look
well he's a good man he his slogan i
love was every vote every county he he
went to every county in pennsylvania it
wasn't different strokes for different
folks
[Applause]
so john fetterman what is it about him
he is such a wonderful populist
candidate look populist very popular
because because he supports the middle
class he supports the little person who
doesn't say that well he actually hasn't
who says i hate the middle class and the
little guy can kiss my ass
a lot of people you know give people a
third finger because they don't raise
their wages and they don't help them
when they're everybody
he's a lieutenant governor he has a
strong record he wants to raise the
minimum wage yes he wants to legal
legalize does he have a personality he
wants to bring factory jobs yes he has a
great personnel you should have him on
as soon as he's ready let me provide you
an alternative i grew up in pennsylvania
the man for the job is dave mccormick
he's he's the uh he's a front-runner
alongside oz right now for the
republican side and he would be a great
u.s senator well i know i was in no i
was in atlantic city but it was the
pennsylvania market that i was watching
on the local tv
it was frightening because the only the
only ad this is why the democrats i know
they're going to get their ass kicked
the only
they couldn't even afford tv ads and all
the like congress candidates that were
yeah
it was like
yeah candidate and they kept saying
conservative like it was the guy's first
name conservative brad goonsburg
is conservative and he's tough and he
will stand up to biden and kill
criminals and rip that dress off your
son you know
conservative brad goonsburg he's
conservative and he shoots things he
doesn't like i was like oh
61 and he hasn't had a stroke yet
right i gotta go to vegas thank you
everybody
you